yes difficult and sometimes  uncomfortable decisions have had to be  made I understand fully that there are  some who were unhappy with those  compromises but this deal delivers what  people voted for and it is in the  national interest  and we can only secure it if we unite  behind the agreement reached in cabinet  yesterday if we do not move forward with  that agreement nobody can know for sure  the consequences that will follow it  would be to take a path of deep and  grave uncertainty when the British  people just want us to get on with it  they are looking to the Conservative  Party to deliver to deliver a brexit  that works for the whole UK a strong  economy that keeps jobs safe and wages  rising and first-class public services  we can rely on an NHS there for all of  us great schools for every child and the  homes that families need that is what  the people we serve expect and that is  what we owe it to them to deliver